the scourge of puppy mills is a
nationwide crisis the Humane Society of
the United States estimates that as many
as two to four million puppy mill dogs
are sold every year it really is a
supply and demand issue you know too
often people think well this is just me
and I'll just get this one puppy or they
think they're rescuing a puppy from a
pet store and the reality is this is a
business and you're not rescuing that
puppy you're simply opening up a cage
for another puppy to be ordered up
because as soon as that cage is empty
there's another puppy coming
it's it's so important that people take
strong consumer action that they make a
choice that they're not going to support
puppy mills
Diana Foster owner of thin Schmidt
German Shepherds fears that licensed dog
breeding facilities like hers could be
mistakenly thought of as puppy mill
operations the puppy mill industry has
really affected our business as well as
other professional breeders as people
really don't know who to weed out and we
really have to gain their trust the
first thing I think that's very
important is ask about the parents you
wanted to see them you want to be able
to touch them and pet them and see what
her temperament is like I think it's
very important for the dogs to have a
really good environment they do need
exercise and social interaction with
other dogs as well as people so that's
very important the environment that
they're raised in for puppy mill dogs
the journey through life is often tragic
but there's a happy ending for the 11
dogs rescued the day Caesar accompanied
LCA
as far as all the dogs that we sent to
the Brittany foundation two of them are
still in foster homes but the rest of
all of them are in permanent homes the
six dogs that Caesar actually helped put
into my truck have all been adopted and
he'll have happy endings one of them
little bit stayed with me i fostered her
for about three weeks she had some
extensive surgery done on her stomach
because she'd given birth six times in
her young life of three years brought
her to a protest and Sharon Osbourne was
walking into the store to purchase a
puppy and I stopped her and I said wait
you know we have some puppies here today
and she said let me see them and I and I
showed her a little bit and she fell in
love and and it worked out hi Cesar it's
Sharon Osbourne I want to thank you and
last chance for animals for rescuing a
little bit because she is now a new
member of the Osborne family and we love
her loads thank you look she can't wait
to get away